[Music]
I've been farming full-time for about
ten years
I rent 650 acres approximately half of
that is in pasture and hay meadow and
alfalfa and then the remaining half is
in cropland and it's corn soybeans oats
and wheat are typically part of the
cropland portion of the acreage in
addition to farming I also work at bon
home high school I am their AG
instructor and their FFA advisor it's a
really neat opportunity to have that
kind of a job because it really
coincides with what I do on the farm and
it really gives me an opportunity to
teach students about things that I'm
passionate about in my life
typically when we start our soils units
depending on the class we always start
with like an overview of soil
characteristics soil texture organic
matter and how all of those different
factors and components are going to
affect the productivity of the soil and
then after we cover that broad overview
of those soil topics we move into a soil
erosion and how we can degrade the soil
with mono cropping continuous residue
room removal you know not having
livestock on the landscape and we tie
all those topics in together and then
they can see how some of the the
management practices that we have in our
operations can really impact long-term
productivity of the soil
some of the things that we'll do as a
slate test the slate test gives a very
simple measure of the biological health
of that soil and then we also do
infiltration tests and then the tabletop
infiltration and runoff test as well on
a typical year given the prices of corn
and soybeans I've been converting some
of those acres usually 25 to 30 acres
into a full season cover crop mix and
that would be planted sometime in May
and with that full season mix it allows
me to graze it midsummer and I can take
the cows off of the pasture they're
allowed to graze that midsummer they go
back to the pasture while the full
season regrows and then they can come
and read graze that in the fall so it
really just gives me more acres to graze
and puts less stress on the pastures
which which is important as well with
cover crops going on the crop ground my
main goals are to build organic matter
have something on the soil surface so
that ground is not bare and then also
help build structure and reduce
compaction those would be my main goals
in addition to that I also want to fix
some nitrogen I want to provide some
livestock feed as well but those would
be my main ones is really just to
protect the land build that organic
matter and improve the soil structure as
well we really do need to start focusing
on soil health because if we look at the
long term productivity of the soil if we
start looking at the some of the weather
patterns that we're starting to deal
with if our soil gets too degraded the
farmer is not going to be making any
money
the main thing that I want my students
to realize is that you don't have to do
it the way that dad and grandpa did it
things have changed there's better
equipment out there to no-till and a lot
more crops he can rotate in hopefully if
they can see some of what I'm doing and
if they can see that some of what I'm
doing is working they don't have to make
changes this year next year but maybe
they start farming in five years or so
down the road they realize you know what
this just isn't quite working maybe we
should try some of what mr. Meese our
talked about keeping your soil covered
soil armor crop rotation diversity
incorporating livestock back into
landscape no-till is obviously the big
one that not tilling it allows all the
worms and microorganisms to work
together and improve your soil health
maybe we should give some of those
practices a try and and see if that
would help what we're dealing with here
on the farm